salut aujourd'hui on va parler de sa
nintendo switch la toute nouvelle
console nintendo faut dire qu'en ce
moment sur youtube cette console se fait
littéralement déglingué pour certains
elle est beaucoup trop cher c'est sûr
qu'elle est très cher par rapport à la
concurrence mais pour d'autres il ya un
procès qui à mon avis est pas un mot
procès on reproche à nintendo d'avoir
sorti une console comme étant une
console de salon alors qu elle
s'apparenterait davantage à une console
portative
sauf qu'en réalité c'est les deux à la
fois mais avant toute chose je commence
à refaire un petit tour pour vous
expliquez moi comment j'ai débuté dans
le monde des consoles
bonsoir mesdames bonsoir mes demoiselles
bonsoir messieurs en réalité j'ai
commencé à jouer avant même que les
consoles existe amstrad cpc 464 à
cassette je jouais à indiana jones sur
cassette c'est là dessus que je joue au
début un vieil ordinateur sur lequel je
joue à des jeux tout aussi vieux en 1989
c'est bien comme ça date le tout premier
street fighter était là dessus tu l'as
en bas là en numéro 3 rambo james bond
batman et même les simpson pour charger
un jeu en réalité tu mettais une demi
heure tu insérer la cassette et pendant
une demi heure elle chargeait le jeu si
jamais j'avais le malheur d'avoir un
problème de lecture s'était planté
c'était pire que le bruit des modems 56k
ce fait pire et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
connu sour disent tu veux ils vont ils
te filer un petit livre avec dans lequel
tu avais des lignes de codes et tu
pouvais te même programme était jeu ça
c'est un jeu de cartes passionnant alors
forcément quand la messe est sorti on
l'a eu ma toute première gameboy
ça c'est d'époque gameboy c'est dans la
poche et oui parce qu'à l'époque avec
quoi il y avait eu la nintendo et ça
c'était même avant la super nintendo
tu vois avec les images bien pourri ça
tu vas nintendo a su garder le meilleur
jeu du monde
tetris qu'on retrouve partout après il
ya eu la super nintendo j'en passe et
des meilleurs nintendo a fait énormément
de consoles moi je me suis arrêté un
petit peu à l'époque de la playstation
j'ai arrêté de jouer parce que je
trouvais je passais beaucoup trop de
temps dessus et qu'on disait à l'époque
aurait elle ne passe pas ton temps à
jouer
ce n'est pas un métier on gagne pas sa
vie avec ça comme quoi il y en a qui
sont bien plantés
côté consoles que personne ne connaît
j'ai eu ça le cdi philips d'une console
qui servait un peu à rien tu avais des
jeunes link zelda astéries
ex un jeu de casino le train fantôme
scotland yard tout ça c'est sorti à
l'époque où la musique électronique
bah c'était ça c'est à l'époque où jean
michel jarre était le roi du monde
les cordes sont remplacé ici par des
rayons laser j'ai aussi eu une bonne
game gir avec des jeux à la cool donc
question jeu vidéo j'en ai brasse et
quelques-uns et pendant quelques années
j'ai décroché
et là je me suis vraiment rien
intéressés quand j'ai commencé à voir la
réalité virtuelle j'ai testé au salon de
l'auto à paris au mois d'octobre dernier
le casque n'a été virtuel de sony et ça
m'a bluffé je me suis vraiment
réintéresser à tout ça et c'est pour ça
que du coup je me suis intéressé à cette
fameuse console là je ne l'est pas elle
sort au mois de mars la mienne est en
carton mais ça fait quand même son petit
effet par l'onda nintendo switch je
trouve que c'est très intéressant comme
concept et je vais te dire pourquoi
à la base cette console a effectivement
fait pour jouer tout seul quand tu te
déplaces tu peux jouer tout seul avec
des manettes sache explique pas le
fonctionnement tu sais comment ça marche
tu peut switcher et c'est le but de la
console directement sur ta télé pourquoi
pas c'est par d'effectivement de jouer à
la maison des à l'extérieur on va pas
pareil forcément la qualité tout de
suite parce que j'ai bien vu que la
qualité ce n'était pas ce qu avait du
mieux par rapport à ce qui se fait sur
le marché par contre c'est là où
nintendo est hyper intelligent il garde
un créneau où il garde tout le temps le
joueur c'est à dire que tu sois chez toi
pour vouloir jouer soit dans la rue tu
sois en déplacement en vacances dans une
salle d attente dans un bus tu peux tout
en jouer au même jeu n'est pas obligé de
changer de console est pas obligé de te
dire par exemple maintient là je suis en
train de jouer avec mon smartphone avec
mes petits jeux de smartphones puis
quand je rentrerai chez moi je pourrai
reprendre ma partie de zelda ou de mario
ou d' aventure de ce que tu veux tu es
pas obligé
tu peux la garder tout le temps et
partout et c'est cette cohérence là qui
est vraiment intéressant je pense que
d'autant plus ce qu'ils ont réussi à
faire et qui est très malin c'est que
cette console tu peux jouer à plusieurs
tu débranches t joystick de chaque côté
tu peux jouer avec des potes tu peux
aussi posé la console avec l'écran qui
apparemment est un peu lourde donc tu
peux la pause et 30 et joystick il ya
plein d'outils qui sont mis en place
pour faciliter le jeu et faciliter
l'accès au jeu donc en réalité tu peux
jouer chez toi sur un écran tu peux
jouer dans les transports tu peux jouer
partout et tout le temps était pas
obligé de jouer seul ça redonne de la
convivialité au jeu à l'époque tout
on joue un peu sa xbox en réseau là tu
peux rejouer avec des potes à des jeux
directement en ayant une vraie
convivialité et ça c'est super
intéressant
là où nintendo a fait un peu une erreur
c'est de la vendre comme une console de
salon alors qu'en réalité c'est pas une
console de salon et c'est pas une
console portative
c'est un espèce d'hybride que tu peux
transporter partout mais je crois qu'ils
ont pas encore trouvé le terme le sortir
en tant que tiens voici notre nouvelle
console hybride c'est un peu bizarre ça
marche pas alors après effectivement il
ya des points faibles
tu vas voir une console qui va être un
petit peu faible niveau graphisme pas
très puissante par rapport à ce qui
s'est sans marcher surtout dans cette
gamme de prix
à la sortie tu auras cinq jeux bon ça
casse pas la baraque mais les éditeurs
vont sortir après si la console
rencontre un vrai succès tous les avis
que j'ai vues sont relativement négatif
sur cette console
parce que en réalité qui parlent de
cette console ce sont les gens qui l'ont
essayé et quelles sont les personnes qui
l'ont essayé sont les gamer les gens qui
s'intéressent ton passionné par les jeux
vidéo et qui ont des chaînes youtube qui
ne parlent quasiment que de jeux vidéo
voire exclusivement de jeux vidéo donc
quand on habitue et qu'on connaît
l'univers du jeu vidéo on a certaines
attentes et en un niveau d'exigence qui
est beaucoup plus élevé mais là il faut
penser autrement à mon avis il faut
penser d'abord au consommateur lambda à
la personne qui aime bien jouer qui va
revenir dans un univers de jeux vidéo ou
quelqu'un qui joue de temps en temps et
je pense plutôt côté famille on n'est
plus dans cette stratégie là à mon avis
famille ados public jeune plus là dedans
et pourquoi pas même des gens qui ont 25
30 35 40 ans parce qu'après tout en
réalité on s'en rend compte avec les
smartphones
on joue dès qu'on a un moment dès qu'on
a un moment où on s'ennuie transports en
commun salles d'attentes tous ces petits
moments là et dans des gaines le
téléphone portable est là au lieu de
dégainer téléphone portable tu dégaine
sa donc le soir quand tu as envie de te
détendre pas console dans le bus par
console chez toi un petit monde des
tentes pas envie de relâcher paraphe
console toilettes par console et ça tu
fais tout le temps et je pense que c'est
vraiment le point fort de la nintendo
switch de vraiment créer une cohérence
en ayant toujours le même jeu du coup tu
joueras plus longtemps at en jeu et tu
pourras aller plus loin dans l'aventuré
sera moins frustrés de te dire j'ai pu
jouer une heure de jean trois heures je
dois partir j'ai un rendez vous je dois
aller chez le médecin je dois faire si
je dois faire ça t'es pas frustré tu
peux jouer tout le temps tu es un gros
gamer qui veut faire des heures d
des heures sur un zelda tu peux pas vous
des lots toilettes tu amènes avec toi
t'es pas frustré et c'est ça qui est
hyper intelligent
même si nintendo qu'on n'aura pas le
même succès que sur la wii ils vont
quand même pouvoir à mon avis rivaliser
parce que tu vas pouvoir jouer à deux
chacun avec son pad directement dans la
main et que pouvoir faire des parties de
dengue sur un petit écran
partout et tout le temps et c'est là
qu'est la force de cette console c'est
pas une console de salon ils sont
plantés ils ont mal communiquer dessus
c'est une excellente console à mon avis
en tout cas le concept est hyper
intéressant il aurait peut-être fallu la
booste un peu plus probablement
descendre le prix par rapport au marché
mais par contre en terme de portes
ativités en termes de durée de jeu et en
termes de plaisir
je pense qu'il ya quand même pas mal de
choses à faire alors après ça réflective
en dépendent du nombre de jeux qui vont
sortir et de scor pouvoir faire avec
mais je pense que fondamentalement
l'idée est bonne il ya une vraie
nouveauté
la nouveauté c'est de pouvoir jouer
partout et tout le temps mais pas
forcément sur des petits écrans on peut
ce câble et sur un grand écran et ça
c'est hyper manens pour conclure je
pense que publique est ciblée c'est pas
le public qui en parle ce qui fait que
ceux qui en parlent qu'en niveau
d'exigence est très élevé pour forcément
très critique avec alors que en réalité
le grand public et l'idée à mon sens des
personnes qui ont développé cette
console était pas du tout là dessus ils
sont peut-être trompés ils auraient
peut-être dû faire un tarif plus
attractif
après il faut effectivement voir ça
représente un coût de revient ou une
console comme sahin en études en
développement pour avoir un produit qui
est rentable parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'univers du jeu vidéo c'est une chose
qui est extrêmement concurrentiel
donc il faut qu'une console et sa propre
particularité il faut qu'elle se place
dans une économie de marché il faut
qu'elle trouve son public et il faut 86
des éditeurs qui veulent bien s'y
intéresse nintendo une place de choix là
dedans
faut pas se planter en moins mais je
donne quand même un avis positif parce
qu' il fallait le faire
et l'idée de fond elle est juste géniale
gros pouce bleus pour nintendo gros
bravo continuez comme ça je pense qu'il
faut laisser du temps il faut voir les
petits ajustements graphiquement il va
pas se passer grand chose non plus sa
patte de devenir dingue
par contre voilà pour les gens qui
aiment jouer tout le temps que par envie
de s'emmerder qu'il a quelque chose de
simple de pratique on a super outil
dis moi c'était d'accord ce que tu en
penses est ce que ces quelques arguments
ont fait mouche au quel cas dis le moi
mais moi un petit commentaire tous les
avis sont les bienvenus est ce que tu
penses vraiment que voilà ça n'a pas sa
place et une console qui ne marchera pas
est ce que toi tu veux l'acheter
est ce que tu peux pas l'acheter donne
moi ton opinion
et puis on verra plus tard peut-être que
je me laisse tenter je vous dis bien
peut-être en attendant merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo
regarde ça là aussi elle très sympa
abonne toi dans la diagonale en bas je
te remercie je t'embrasse et je te dis à
très bientôt